so you're at CNN I mean granted you do
it one time yeah one time a year I'm not
one employee I'm like I'm a contracted
but even in your diet for Higher One Day
a year so now you see all this going on
at CNN this guy Chris flick who told you
you can't drink on New Year's Eve he's
the one who ordered you not to drink I
thought it was fungal what what a bungle
now part of the fun in my opinion of you
on New Year's Eve was you getting
blasted everybody ridiculous I don't
want to see me make Anderson giggle
right and they love to see him do shots
by the way we had a great show this New
Year's Eve we were Silly we we did
mystery shots we did everything we could
I mean you know we were doing shots of
pickle juice and trying to guess what it
was you know with with glass of funny
glasses on I mean we did what we could
we did everything we could you know or
to get around it but
it was just yeah it was a stupid move I
mean it was what people say to me today
when I walk down the street please tell
me they're gonna let you drink this year
it didn't people all of our guests we
had Kevin Hart he did like four minutes
live on New Year's Eve about how stupid
CNN was not to let us drink so how is
that paying off for CNN so as a fellow
television executive like Chris slick
was he the wrong guy for the job uh at
CNN in your opinion I don't know the
answer to that I mean I I guess because
it didn't work out you know uh are you
happy he is gone because now there's an
opportunity when you appear on uh the
New Year's Eve show that you will be
able to drink it was my hope that had he
remained that maybe we could have said
to him listen this clearly did not work
out last year let's revisit this issue
so that was my plan if he was there I
would have hoped that he would have said
yeah but you personally because you
worked there were you happy with this
development
I didn't really care I just want to be
able to drink on New Year's Eve and I
want Anderson to be happy that's right I
want my friend to be happy
foreign